ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome the
Preservation Hall Jazz Band.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - PRESERVATION
HALL JAZZ BAND, "I
THINK I LOVE YOU"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - PRESERVATION
HALL JAZZ BAND]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - PRESERVATION HALL
JAZZ BAND, "THAT'S IT"]
CLINT MAEDGEN: Mark Braud.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - PRESERVATION HALL
JAZZ BAND, "THAT'S IT"]
[APPLAUSE]
CLINT MAEDGEN: Mark
Braud, y'all.
[APPLAUSE]
CLINT MAEDGEN: And I'd be sorely
remiss not to point out
Joe Lastie on the
drums, y'all.
[MUSIC - PRESERVATION HALL JAZZ
BAND, "DEAR LORD (GIVE ME
STRENGTH)"]
ANNOUNCER: Ladies
and gentlemen--
MARK BRAUD: Rondell Johnson.
ANNOUNCER: --Preservation
Hall Jazz Band.
One more round of applause,
please.
[APPLASE]
MARK BRAUD: One more
time, y'all.
Rondell Johnson on the
tuba, come on.
Freddie Lonzo on trombone.
Little Joe Lastie,
on the drums.
Ben Jaffe, on the tuba.
Ricky Monie, on the piano.
Clint Maedgen on tenor
saxophone.
Today is his 81st birthday.
Charlie Gabriel.
Thank you so much, y'all.
On trumpet, my mother's favorite
trumpet player, Mark
Braud, thank you.
Preservation Hall Jazz Band.
[MUSIC - PRESERVATION
HALL JAZZ BAND]
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
give it up one more
time for Preservation
Hall Jazz Band.
BEN JAFFE: Yeah, last year
we celebrated our 50th
anniversary, and we actually
celebrated
here at Carnegie Hall.
And we're back again
this year.
It's a different celebration
for us.
It's not just a celebration of
our incredible history, but
it's a celebration
of our future.
This is the first time in 50
years that we've made a
recording entirely of our
own compositions.
And actually, most of them we
played for you today, and it
looked like you liked them.
So they like them.
That last song, that was Rondell
Johnson from New
Orleans, Louisiana.
From a great musical family.
His great uncle--
RONDELL JOHNSON: My
great uncle, yeah.
BEN JAFFE: Great uncle, Kid
Joseph, was a bass player at
Preservation Hall.
This is Freddie Lonzo, he played
with my father many
years ago in the Olympia
Brass Band.
Joe comes from one of the great
musical families in our
city, the Lastie family, just
about everybody in his family
is one of our city's
great musicians.
Mark and I have known each
other since high school.
We went to the New Orleans
Center for Creative Arts in
New Orleans together.
And both of his uncles, Wendell
Brunious and the late
great John Brunious, have
both been leaders of the
Preservation Hall Band.
And now it's a fourth
generation?
Fourth generation New Orleans
musician, Mark Braud, is up
there in that chair.
And sitting next to him,
the scoundrel.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN JAFFE: He keeps
telling us that
this is his 81st birthday.
We don't believe him because
none of us have actually ever
seen his birth date.
But we'll believe
you, Charlie.
Because last year we
celebrated his
80th birthday here.
That's right, last year we
celebrated his 80th birthday
in New York and we're
back this year.
Today is actually Charlie's
81st birthday.
CHARLIE GABRIEL: 18
years old, man.
BEN JAFFE: 18.
18!
[APPLAUSE]
CHARLIE GABRIEL:
Don't do this.
BEN JAFFE: And Charlie comes
from, again, one of our great
musical families
in New Orleans.
He's also a fourth generation
New Orleans musician and he
has three generations of
musicians that are continuing
to play in New Orleans.
Down there at the end,
on the piano.
Known this gentleman for
many, many years.
He's been a member of the
Preservation Hall on and off
since 1982.
And he knew my father real
well back in the day.
And that's the professor,
one of the most
talented musicians I know.
That's Rickie Monie
on the piano.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN JAFFE: And then, all the way
down there on the end, the
saxophone and vocals.
This is one of our
dear friends.
That's Mr. Clint Maedgen
down there.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN JAFFE: And yeah,
we became friends.
I don't know if you all are
familiar with this gentleman
Jim James and this band
My Morning Jacket.
If you're not, they're
incredible and they've become
part of our life.
They're from Louisville,
Kentucky, and we met them down
in New Orleans.
Jim came and did a recording
with us for a benefit project
post-Katrina.
And out of that first recording,
I mean, the moment
we met we immediately struck
up a friendship.
And he invited us to go out on
tour with My Morning Jacket.
So a New Orleans jazz
band touring with a
rock and roll band.
And it was amazing.
It was awesome.
It was a great experience for
us and it opened up a whole
new world to our music.
And it has led us to here,
today, to me and Jim producing
our newest project, "That's
It!", which I think they have
some copies back there
for y'all too.
Yeah, it's unbelievable that
after 50 years of playing
repertoire from the greats, from
Jelly Roll Morton, from
Louis Armstrong, from King
Oliver and all the greats,
we're now having an opportunity
to create a new
book of standards.
And that's something that
we're real proud of.
We all cherish our history
and our traditions.
And for those of you that have
been to New Orleans, you know
how important that is to us.
It's almost--
without music there
wouldn't be a New
Orleans, really, you know.
And it's because of these
gentlemen's family that we're
all up here on stage today.
So if you don't mind, with
that being said, Charlie,
would you mind if we all sang
you a happy birthday song
right now man?
Oh, I'm singing it?
I'm singing.
MARK BRAUD: I can lead
it if you want.
BEN JAFFE: Lead, you lead it.
Yeah, you lead it.
[MUSIC - PRESERVATION HALL JAZZ
BAND, "HAPPY BIRTHDAY"]
[APPLAUSE]
CHARLIE GABRIEL: I've been
trying to tell friends here
that I'm a recycled teenager.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHARLIE GABRIEL: I am
a recycled teenager.
ANNOUNCER: All right, one big
round of applause, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN JAFFE: This is supposed to
be a Q&A. So I've been giving
a lot of answers,
no questions.
Public forum, should
we open it for--
ANNOUNCER: Yeah, do you guys
have any questions for them?
BEN JAFFE: Or do you just want
to say how awesome we are?
[APPLAUSE]
BEN JAFFE: I think they probably
want more music, is
actually what they--
ANNOUNCER: What do you say?
BEN JAFFE: Yeah, I mean, you
guys, you don't have to go
back to work, right?
Well, you're at work,
what am I saying.
This is work.
ANNOUNCER: Thanks.
[MUSIC - PRESERVATION
HALL JAZZ BAND]
[APPLAUSE]